hey guys i'm ryan right hello i'm
veronica six-toes today we're checking
out a music video for a song that
Veronica just posted a cover of yeah the
Taylor Swift song bad blood but this one
features Kendrick Lamar now I love the
bad blood song I never get tired of
hearing Veronica play it so catchy no I
like your version anyway I like Kendrick
Lamar let's check this out
cause baby now we've got bad blood you
know we used to be mad love so take a
look what you've done cause baby now
we've got bad blood hey I can't take it
back look where I'm at we was on D like
the EOC remember that my TLC was quite
ODI d my facts now POV of you and me
similar Iraq I don't hate you but I hate
to critique overrate you these beats of
a dark heart use basslines to replace
you take time and erase you love down
here no more no I don't fear no more
remember when you try to write me off
remember when you thought I'd take a
loss don't you remember you thought that
I would need you follow procedure
remember or what you got amnesia it was
my season for battle wounds battle scars
body bumped bruised stabbed in the back
brimstone fire jumping through still all
my life I got money and power and you
gotta live with the bad blood now
now we've got problems and I don't think
we can solve them you made a really deep
card baby now we've got bad Oh bad dates
don't fix bullet holes you say sorry
just for show but you never show so take
a look what you've done
we've got bad blood you know we used to
be mad love so take a look what you've
done cause baby now we've got bad blood
hey oh well done that was one of the
coolest music videos I've ever seen oh
yeah okay no sex tonight no sex for you
tonight you messed up my hair you just
got me blue balls all those cameos man
lera [ __ ] ton of cameos I love the
homage to a whole bunch of sci-fi flicks
yeah that was really funny see it a
little bit of matrix in there you get a
little bit of fit Ellen you'd a bunch to
get Tron there's a whole bunch of things
in there that are
very much homage it was so cool to watch
nothing taller than watching a bunch of
badass chicks yeah they were all really
hot they're all really sexy mm-hmm mmm
baby damn it you do this when or without
the [ __ ] camera here you will always
do this um I'm sorry I don't know what
you want from me no no dude no it's your
me are you on your period because that
would mean you got bad blood yes yes
that would explain why you are not drawn
to me right now like you normally are
here's a photo of Instagram now you guys
don't see me shirtless but there's a
reason why it's cuz I'm too sexy for her
if I were to pose next to her with my
shirt off and she was in her bikini she
would just feel embarrassed
I totally outshine me it's [ __ ] up now
they're all thinking you're hot yeah I'm
the hot one now Lena Dunham
what is the creator of the show girls
and it's my absolute favorite show of
all time so for her to have a little
cameo and that is so badass
I met Selena Gomez once when I was like
15 I had a like 10 minute conversation
with her she was cute then but her looks
I've really evolved and so is Taylor
Swift oh you mean like the hot yeah yeah
I've met Selena Gomez - I know that's
right you work with her on Wizards of
Waverly Place
we hung out Taylor Swift got a lot cuter
well in this she's it's not that she got
a lot cuter she's always been really
cute she changed its up her style all
the time in this video oh yeah she just
put you know she's really dolled up in
this okay she looks really good yeah
that was a badass video yeah that's it
action I thought only the beginning was
gonna be like something cool than it was
just break into a video who's the
director of this again I feel like I
know this guy before I've seen some of
his work he did the Power Rangers short
film the Wonder looks so cool love the
way you lie space-bound
we damn know this guy is I've seen a lot
of this guy she did a lot of music
videos he did hero by Enrique Iglesias
that's the one I was gravitated to you
well power and your shirt was awesome
nice very cinematic
oh it was [ __ ] awesome I love the way
every moment was shot the style was
great the tone of it was awesome and I
like Kendrick Lamar in it like his rap
actually worked really well it's
interesting is I wouldn't hadn't
imagined that imagery to go with that
song like even the Kendrick Lamar
version but it worked really well now
when I hear that song I'll think of it
differently
yeah me too I think of a bunch of hot
chicks whipping ass whuppin well whippin
or kicking you can whip my ass I mean I
bought that thing like two months ago
and you still owe me use it on me or the
strap-on anyway guys thanks for tuning
into the real rejects if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you can check out
Veronica's channel or I said earlier she
has a cover of this song up and running
right now and actually Veronica I'm
gonna plug you baby
ahhh she's up for female YouTube artists
of the month of May 2015 you can check
out her channel you can vote for her and
if you like her stuff definitely vote
for her there's a link of the
description box where you can go ahead
and vote for Veronica
you can vote every day up until May 27
also you don't have to create an account
to do it that is the most annoying
process is creating a [ __ ] account or
connecting it with your Facebook to
[ __ ] vote but you have to do that and
if she wins we might finally have sex
and you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter if we get enough
followers we can get product placement
Daniel Butler hey guys I'm a huge fan of
your channel keep up the great work you
guys are hilarious Thank You Daniel
Butler
you know Daniel Butler is actually a sex
position that Veronica sometimes does on
me yeah yeah the the butler is what it
is that's where she serves food to me up
the bunghole yeah we try all kinds of
things strawberries bananas of course
bananas it's mainly fruit apples mm-hmm
watermelon and sometimes steak cook
steak but raw chicken is the way to go
raw chicken and I'm literally feeling a
little bit nauseous right now but that's
the butler disgusting oh you have a
girlfriend congratulations
you should try the butler with her